Kourtney Kardashian splits from Yoon's
Benzema reese witherspoon on reviving
Elwood's while the CW breaks new ground
with fat woman hey guys this is the
daily Deni just out here trying to keep
up with those Kardashian's it seems like
it's one thing after the other with them
and this time it's Elder Courtney making
headlines et has learned core and
boyfriend Yoon's Benjamin broke up after
two years of dating vacationing it
snapping sexy pics together TMZ was
first to report the news after photos
surface of the 25 year old male model
romping around Mexico with model Jordan
Ozuna who has been linked with Tyga and
Justin Bieber a source tells us though
they are not romantically linked it was
nothing more than friends just having
fun together on the beach we're told the
couple decided it wasn't going to work
out but it was the 39 year old mother of
three who ended things our source says
their age difference ultimately played a
part quote Yoon's is young and although
mature for his age him and Kourtney are
at different stages in their lives I
checked and they unfollowed each other
on Instagram which is the tell-all sign
of a split in 2018 right Yoon's last
post is from his romantic Italian
getaway with court in July that's still
on the gram as is this revealing bikini
pic used was up in arms over when
Kourtney posted on her page the break-up
comes just after Kourtney had a
screaming match with her sisters that
aired on Sunday's Keeping Up with the
Kardashians the girl seems to be going
through it and somewhere Sophia Ricci is
screaming Real Talk do you think she'll
get back together with Scott Disick
Kourtney has said her kids are her
priority so we'll see but someone who
seems to have perfected being a badass
mom with the even more killer career
Reese Witherspoon she just launched her
new Direct TV series shine with Reese
putting the spotlight on female
storytellers and she's even making time
to bring back everyone's favorite
feminist
my name is Elwood and for my admissions
essay I'm gonna tell all of you at
Harvard why I'm gonna make an amazing I
have to tell you we are beyond excited
about Legally Blonde coming back how
thrilled are you to be stepping back
into those iconic stilettos oh it's
gonna be so fun I I got to go to a
meeting the other day where we talked
about all the new plot points and all
the characters and some returning
characters and some new characters and
it's I mean I got so excited just in the
meeting I was like this is gonna be good
okay so we're in for some good stuff
what is Elle Woods up to this time I
can't tell you it never hurts to try
mmm I see okay okay throwing ice cream
at Meryl Streep yeah I did that it's
probably a it's a top five moment in my
career pressure but I can't remember the
other four not many people could say
they pelted Meryl Streep with an ice
cream cone and now many folks can say
they helped Keith Urban paper snacks
that's right a retired New Jersey
teacher with read got the surprise of
her life when she thought he was just a
cusper and need at Medford wah-wah
convenience store apparently keith was
short some cash and she offered to pick
up the tab I'll tell you what Ruth is
still shook by this and told local news
outlets CBS 3 all about it so what's
your name Ruth Reed and who did you meet
a couple days ago Keith Urban tell us
about that
I didn't know was Keith Urban I didn't
think he had enough money to pay for his
thing so I said I would pay for him and
briefly when he told me who he was I
didn't believe it was him and he was
very gracious and let me get my picture
taken with him and that's that's it in a
nutshell
it appears Ruth also tweeted Keith to
say thank you for the picture writing
I'm a celebrity with my Facebook friends
now love that all right guys before we
sign off there is some really really
exciting casting news that's got me and
fans alike talking CWS cast Ruby Rose as
that woman the DC Comics character will
first make her debut as Kate Kane in the
arrowverse crossover event in December
but get this there will be a modern spin
on this bat woman as her character will
be out lesbian now this is major for a
lot of reasons but mainly if the show
gets picked up to series that woman
would be the first gay lead character
and a live-action superhero series now
not all heroes wear a case book who
doesn't want to see a crime-fighting
superhero in all kinds of different
shapes and forms Ruby says she's an
emotional wreck over this news and is
beyond thrilled and honored get it girl
we have more on Batwoman and all of
these stories up on etl Minecon i'll see
you guys tomorrow
[Music]